إنه فن بسيط للغاية ، أليس كذلك
فقط بحاجة إلى مقص
قصاصات من الورق وبعض الغراء و
يمكنك فعل شيء بنفسك
يمكن أن تعبر عن نفسك
في حالتي أواجه القصص
[موسيقى]
الملحم
اسمي وروزا عمري 83 سنة
بدأ القطع في عام 1969 لذلك هناك
50 طنًا من الورق الذي قطعناه ونحن
الغراء هو فن شعبي بسيط للغاية
التي نجدها
قبل عشرة قرون في البلدان
الأوروبية ولكن أيضا في أفريقيا
أفعل ذلك بالألوان كثيرًا
قطع بالأبيض والأسود
أصبحت لوحاتي بمرور الوقت
دعنا نقول متوسط ​​سعر باهظ الثمن بعض الشيء
فقط 4400 جنيه لكن هناك البعض
هذا الجدول أغلى بكثير إذا كان كذلك
في أول ما فعلته هو ذلك
أعطيت زوجي منذ 50 عامًا
مر الوقت بسرعة كبيرة ولكن لديك
ما زال ممتعا إنه جميل
ذاكرة
حتى هنا هو جعل انقطاع
مقص مقص هناك أيضا
التقنيات الأخرى التي لديها الليزر و
القاطع هناك مؤامرة الأرض أنا أيضا أنا
قطع فقط بالمقص و
ملاقط صغيرة
قطع وغراء أبيض
[موسيقى]
يمكننا الذهاب لعبة صغيرة جدا
قطع الأحرف التي تحتوي على
سنتيمتر لعملي أعتقد ذلك
إنه اللون الأكثر أهمية
نعلم أن الورق يعطيني أفكارًا عنه
دائما الخيال
كان علي أن أذهب إلى باريس للبحث عنه
اثنين من الضحك لأن كل البني على
مختلف قد يستغرق مني واحدة
أسبوع قد يستغرق مني
أيضا ثلاثة أسابيع أنا استنساخها
من الواضح أن هناك دائمًا منازل
الحسد في الجبال
[موسيقى]
هذه حفلة كبيرة
من أين ينحدر الفلاحون
أسلحة المراعي واستحى ذلك
هل سأحصل على بعض الخريف حقًا
فعلت هذا العام أعتقد واحدة
الخمسينيات عرضت في جنيف 1
عرضت الكثير في زيورخ كثيرًا
مرات في نيويورك مرتين ماذا
يهمني هو أن أقول أ
قصة والناس سعداء
لمشاهدة هذه القصة
احب عملي
[موسيقى]